[Music]
hey everyone
scott mccartney here 2020 wasn't a
normal year for travel
or anything air travel hasn't been this
disrupted
since 9 11 and the pandemic has been
much worse
but like every other year planes still
got stuck on the tarmac for hours
arrived late to their destinations and
bags still got lost
we've dug into loads of data that all
airlines tracked
and compiled rankings in seven
categories
for the best and worst major u.s
airlines of the year
let's start with formal complaints okay
here we go this is what really mattered
to consumers last year
in the study period there were more than
97
000 complaints filed at the department
of transportation
that's only a small part of angry
customers that actually
take the trouble to file a complaint
formally
but a year earlier there were only 15
000 complaints
more than 83 000 of those ninety seven
thousand complaints
were about refunds refund complaints
increased more than five thousand
percent
united and frontier were the big
offenders
both of them changed rules during the
pandemic and both made it really
difficult for customers to get refunds
that they were owed
remember when an airline cancels a
flight you are supposed to be entitled
to the option of a refund next
reliability which airlines are better at
getting you where you want to go
this category is on time arrivals the
industry
average for on-time arrivals was 84
of scheduled flights in 2019
the average was 79 5 points lower
delta was darn good at 87
and even with the skies open a legion
could only get
73 of its flights to the gate on time
next tarmac delays we look at
two hour tarmac delays that's kind of
the pain threshold for passengers stuck
in a cabin right
the numbers were small this year but
still there was significant variation
southwest had only 42 flights that sat
on the ground for two hours
with passengers aboard delta had 206.
next category mishandled baggage
[Music]
here some of the improvement came from
airlines in their systems
not from lighter loads southwest started
scanning bags
and monitoring the health of airport
baggage systems
and moved up to number two southwest had
the best improvement
americans rate of miss sandal bags was
down 24 percent
that's good but that wasn't nearly
enough to get it out of the baggage
seller
extreme delays this category is flights
delayed 45 minutes or more you're not
necessarily sitting on the airplane
but you are inconvenienced in other
words when things go wrong
they go bad wrong and there's wide
variation among airlines
only two percent of southwest flights
fell into this category
but eight percent of allegiant flights
canceled flights cancellations were huge
this past year right
but the department of transportation
says a flight is canceled if it's
scrubbed within seven days of departure
before that it's considered a schedule
change
so a lot of pandemic impact came in
schedule changes
the industry officially canceled six
percent of its flights in 2020 that's a
big number
especially compared to less than two
percent of the flights that were
canceled in 2019
involuntary bumping okay
so with few people flying how could
airlines possibly overbook flights
and involuntary bump passengers they did
all pandemic long not as many of course
but still hundreds of people delta
however
bumped only five passengers in the 12
months covered by the study
it got tens of thousands of passengers
to voluntarily change their flights
delta offered sweet incentives to do
that american by contrast
but more than 5 000 american actually
accounted for 77
of all u.s airline bumping over the last
12 months
the overall winner in airline
performance last year
southwest southwest was just
consistently good
at the top in most categories the one
exception was cancellations
it took southwest longer than other
airlines to publish
new schedules so it canceled a lot of
flights close to departure
but otherwise consistently good service
at southwest
and very few complaints the overall
loser
american again american has been last
or next to last in 12 of the 13 years
we've done the scorecard american had
trouble with long delays
baggage handling and bumping passengers
american wasn't very punctual compared
to others there was no category
where american airlines was any better
than the middle of the pack
pandemic or no american has work to do
to become a more reliable airline
don't you long for the days when you got
delayed because there were so many
planes trying to go somewhere
next year maybe worse airline
performance will really be a good thing